So, let's look at our exceptions with ROB quiz solution. At the point,
where this divide has an exception,
this is what we have. When we go to the exception handler for this divide,
what should be happening is that the instructions before it has finished and
the instructions after it have not finished, as far as the programmer is
concerned. So, what we need to really do, because programmer really sees only
what has committed here is the fact that this is done and this is done needs to
be undone. So basically, this instruction is flushed from the pipeline.
It behaves as if it was not executed at all, this instruction and
this instruction, as well. So, pretty much what we do is when we have
an exception such as divide by 0, the correct state of the processor should be
right before this instruction if we were doing these instructions one at a time.
So, what we do is write all back the execution of all these instructions.
How do we do that? Well, we have already committed this instruction before,
it has to stay committed, we cannot uncommit instructions.
This instruction has been executed and this one has been done. What we do, is,
we wait for them to commit. So, what's going to happen is, this instruction will
eventually commit once is done executing, and then this one was already done, so
we can very quickly commit afterwards. Now we reach the point where
the divide carries this exception condition into the commit with it so
when we try to commit the divide we realize we cannot do that.
And that's the point at which we stop committing, flush everything that follows
the divide from the pipeline so these instructions now become unexecuted,
meaning we haven't even fetched them as far as the program is concerned and
this is the point at which we jump to the exception handler. So
pretty much at the point where we call in the exception handler, what you have
is some instructions have committed, some of them haven't been even fetched.
They have been actually fetched but we have discarded them so they
behave like they haven't been fetched. And that's the point where the control is
transferred to the exception handler instead of this way, so that's very
much like a branch misprediction except that it, it happens on an exception.